I'm so excited that it's finally fall
and I have started to incorporate fall transitional wardrobes
and we're switching the makeup up
so I just got 4 new Revlon lipsticks
they're all super Moody for fall
and I wanna try them on with you
because Revlon is my favourite drugstore lipstick
and they can do no wrong so I have four shades right here
let's try em first one is Rum Raisin
very Rachel Green
the next is vampire love
this one's in the same shade family
but definitely darker and definitely a little bit more blue toned
this is Raisin Rage
could I have little bit of the makeup
you want some lipstick
so this one is more like a brick red
which I really like but definitely not like as Berry toned as I would like
little more orange to it okay
actually this is growing on me
I think I do really like this now
this is definitely the darkest one
this is black cherry and I've worn this for years
now this one is a truly vampy
perfect for Halloween and fall season
burgundy Berry lip what do you think
do you like my lipstick um
it's too darkish
I guess he's not a fan